just like the mr. kuffs variation its
let's do Denis a little market to you
violins up is great now because we
haven't shown them that although you may
have seen this touches of them and I saw
our trailers on the television so we're
gonna do the intro who will not talk
over it oh you don't talk or yeah we do
not oh that was that an issue okay what
do you I leave so there's ice cream in
Outworld chubby not your last go at me
cuz you don't know that so you don't
know it is you they don't realize that I
can't hear anything so you're not stupid
it's just not here well so one thing you
will first of all noticed like every
variation fisticuffs there is a visual
indicator to tell you which one you're
using besides up in the corner he's
aware of those he's got the brass
knuckle bling on thick to the cage rings
to this hands Center so let's kind of
get started and talk about what stuff
what kind of moves are always with
Johnny Cage okay um so everyone should
be familiar with this pretty traditional
moves
resulting pop up they have to get a
pop-up and then he's got currently in
this trade he has this blip kick or at
variations he also has you wanna do the
threat yeah one of the pretty unique
things and very damaging things in this
variation is that when patrons to danger
mode help he gets all of his redstone
yes an easter egg and easter egg that so
yeah so as he has this he will get a new
stroll he has a neutral here
so as he's read he gets more more help
more than enough more uh more damage
I'll show real quick the the stuff he
kind of gets with fisticuffs okay so in
this uh this variation he has this club
there is nothing together there and you
can see he's gonna blank coming off
knuckles while he has this he does a
chip damage increase so if you want to
block there you'll see here's little
floor so it was the average so you see
it's very minor right now we hacked
evade this it's pretty considerable yeah
so this this this Johnny Cage is a
really good Johnny Cage to this will
favor in the Russian the aggressor or
someone like because we render the
communication k9 getting in there in the
corner dudes chip damage is really like
yep where he shot especially especially
with the run
after you knock down get me down speak
up a little bit for the guys there later
so right here you should read all of
these notice the damage they're pretty
chunky right but um are are too right
the e X shadow kick here full screens
hard to see that their video he also has
a new string as well which is this is
the coup de Gras this will kill you but
will will show you right will kill you
with it so I'll do it with it here if
you hold away you do this he kind of
does a little flurry punch normally you
know it's pretty devastating but when
you have this buff go to a super cheap
mode and then
see down in the corner that is just yeah
you can do a lot of crazy you know
classic a joke so that's really good yet
growing the autograph down as usual so
that's a really good thing for guys who
really like getting in there rushing in
doing their damage
turning on chip and ending a match real
quick that was stay around them now two
more variations to show you real quick I
played a lot of these variations and
they all are so good in different ways
today I'm a tomato painting with styles
so start out with there Mary Anne here
this is one of my favorites Johnny
throws out the old call me here in a
second I don't know if Raiden has a
phone the new phones
there's teleports new teleports yeah you
followed me you need me here has anyone
ever agreed with that statement where
the shades this is called stunt double
and there's just one major reason it's
called that yeah and this one he does
lose the flip kick but he does gain this
he's got his little truck trusty a stunt
double there which gives him two charges
of his specialist physical physical
special move so he's got one shadow kick
that he can shoot or shoot my other one
I'm also able to follow them up so say I
were shooting this out here I can kind
of chase after it you know let me get
so like an example pretty much after any
kind of string you might want to know
power yourself up right there and you
can do some charging run combo like that
early cooking yourself save money first
run me to I'm just gonna feel like an
hour off like oh let's see so he's got
also his fireball and in this version
they straight go and this one you still
get double so the mimic does yeah this
one's great
I know like when I play cage I'm always
I always trying to do wake up shadow
kick all the timings you know you're
gonna get punished that way but here
your shadow kick will you can do it for
mid screen yeah you know that's one of
the things too like it's kind of um you
see a lot of projectile here gets a
single projectile single hitting move
and they throw it out
the other day I really put too much
serious time in but after these fetch
few days I realized a lot of cool but
like so he wants to like a fireball or
something let's see
well I wasted I basically like anybody
word is own someone now he has a pretty
much instant like you know get right
next to me kind of move but yeah I mean
obviously that people are stuff is
pretty pretty so that that Johnny Johnny
has a very good way of cups you can stay
mid screen but he also has some stuff to
get in quickly
yep using the mimic all dynamics he get
a lot of good juggles with the uppercut
move um that's one thing I know if you
want to show but we he does have that
the uppercut regular mimic version you
also get but that's one with that is
that it in that variation select new
fighter here we got one more variation
which i think is pretty awesome and i
think we're going to see a lot of stuff
maybe even out of the higher level
community using this one quite a bit too
I think data findings all very viable
yeah yeah they all have vocab we're
gonna get to that I think we're gonna
get to mocap here in a second I know ice
to see yeah must everything be a joke
yeah it does ring me you'll have no idea
what they just said I don't know if they
said either we got later
this is a list Johnny Cage now what what
can a list do um this is kind of a
technical little trickster kind of fake
outmanoeuvre variation he can he still
have the foot kick here but most of the
specials he can now charge kind of -
canceled in and out of so if I just do
the regular flip get regular foot they
can't really jump in but if I get any
kind of held version of it easier to
give me any kind of juggle either the
full version gives the same thing is a
way to and other changes or another
variations the best rate away from this
one you're also a passionately charging
up that much - yeah and as well
hopefully have a shout so I was able to
multiple vendors there's a lot of
district variation for sure the one big
thing this one that's gonna create a lot
of unsafe situations make them safe if
you got meter is in this one it's nut
punch it can be me to burn under action
so normally in the other versions of PBX
that nut punch you're pretty much
committed to it and if they block you
have to eat the recovery actually a
pecan wood in this one I see a hit look
I can be run at any time and go ready to
be good so you can kind of throw it out
will be millions who have a metered
reporting there's pretty much respect
okay well like six not much you do a
nice job on that
thank you don't think you might get
rewarded for doing who knows you might
do something that's deaf Johnny Cage
right there in a nutshell